طفلي الرضيع لا يتنفس ، أحتاج إلى مساعدة
أم جديدة مذعورة تتصل بالرقم 9-1-1 9-1-1
ما هو موقع الطوارئ الخاص بك
والمرسل تيم جونز على الطرف الآخر
صوت هادئ مجمّع
يغرق في أسوأ حالاتها  في اللحظة التي احتجت فيها إلى أن
أكون الأفضل ، يمكن أن أكون
بوتشيني بيفرلي تقول إنها قد أعطت
ابنها البالغ من العمر شهرين إليوت حمامًا
وكان نوعًا من الأنف ، لذا قمت بشفط
أنفه وفاضت الدماء
من أنفه  وفمه
وتوقف عن التنفس ،
لقد اعتمد جون منذ ست سنوات في
وحدة إرسال الطوارئ للمرشد أوهايو
بشكل غريزي على تدريبه ،
سنبدأ الإنعاش القلبي الرئوي ، حسنًا ،
أتذكر فقط التفكير في أطفالي في ذلك
الوقت وهم يقولون ما أريده كان هذا
من خلال المراجعة تأكد من أنني
أوضح تعليماتي ، تأكد من أنني أتحقق من
كل تدريب مربع فردي بيفرلي حول
كيفية إحياء ابنها حتى العد معها
لأنها أعطت ضغطات على الصدر ، قم بذلك 30
مرة ، وسأحسب لك
واحد اثنان ثلاثة 15 16  17 18 أنت تفعل
رائع ، كان الأمر كما لو كان في
غرفة معيشتي معي يتحدث معي من خلاله وأخبرني
أنه
يمكنني القيام بذلك
وفعلت ذلك ، لقد تحرك قليلاً
عندما وصل المسعفون بعد دقائق
كان إليوت يتنفس وأتذكر أنني ذهبت
إلى الخلف وحصلت على كأس  من الماء
أعتقد أنه كان ومن تلك
الأشياء التي قلت صلاة سريعة
وأنت تعلم تأكد من أن الطفل على ما يرام
الآن إليوت في المنزل سعيدًا وبصحة جيدة
ومع ذلك لا يزال من غير الواضح
سبب توقفه عن التنفس.
أسابيع في المستشفى
يتعافى المرسلون في كثير من الأحيان لا
يتعلمون نتيجة أولئك الذين ساعدوا
حتى هذا اليوم.
مرحباً ،
كيف حالك جيد ، كيف أنت سعيد
لمقابلتك ،
شكرًا لك ، مرحبًا بك ، لقد
قمت بعمل رائع  وظيفة لطيفة للغاية ، حيث
منح رئيس الإطفاء لجون
خطاب شكر على عمله ، وهو يجلس
بجوار رسالة شكر خاصة جدًا
تلقاها من جدة إليوت ، إنه
مجرد رؤيته هنا ، إنه شيء آخر على
الرغم من أن جون يقول أفضل العلاقات العامة
تأتي aise من معرفة التأثير الذي أحدثه
على هذه الأم والابن ، مرحباً يا صديقي ،
الذين لم يعودوا غرباء ، الحمد لله ،
هناك أشخاص موجودون هناك
لمساعدتنا عندما نكون في مواقف مثل
هذه ، قل مرحباً
مرشد العشب cnn ohio